what if i told you hiring and going on a
first date have a lot in common here's
what i mean by it you have a gun on a
date and you're like she's beautiful oh
my god he's so handsome this is it this
is my girl i'm gonna commit right six
twelve month city you're telling your
friends i should have never dated this
girl never dated this guy why because
you were impressed by looks high rink is
the same just because you see a
ridiculous resume with great college
great whatever whatever's on the resume
doesn't mean this is the right person to
hire for your company today i'm going to
share with you 10 things to keep in mind
before you hire employees and i'm going
to save you millions of dollars
[Music]
okay so stick around till the very end
i'm gonna have a pdf for you and extra
bonus content and if you like this
content give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let me get
right into it number one so before
hiring anybody
let's just say you come to your first
interview here's what i do moving
forward number one i give you an
assignment this is what it sounds like
so you come to the first interview like
hey john how you doing great tell me
about yourself background why do you
want this shop papa papa fantastic are
you a reader johnny i am fantastic at
our company we believe in reading books
and improving
uh i'm going to give you a book to read
as an assignment before our second
interview you should see the reaction
every time i say this this is the
reaction
you you want me to read a book i do
before your second interview
everybody says the same thing they go
oh no one's ever asked me to do this
before i totally understand it's not
common with a lot of companies but it's
normal for us are you open to the idea i
am here's the book i want you to read it
i want you to write a one-page paper on
it and within a week how long do you
think it'll take for you to finish it i
think i need about a week fantastic a
week from now we'll come back for your
second interview great great johnny
thank you for coming out we wish you
nothing but the very best he leaves now
here's what's going to happen
before he even told you that he's going
to do the paper he told himself already
there's no way i'm going to read this
book he's just bullshitting you right
and he'll leave
but the 20
chance that he did read his book and he
comes back that tells you he follows
direction and that tells you he's got
getting deadlines done you just learned
80 of the things that frustrate a bad
employee at a company right up front
in less than a week then he or she comes
back with the paper and they say here's
what i got from the book in the back of
your mind you're saying
he has no idea i'm about to hire this
person because they have the right
characteristics of coming through i
value that if you value that start doing
that moving forward with anybody you
hire on w-2 jobs okay number two before
you hire anybody a lot of times people
are like well i'm just going to do a
background check right here's what i'm
going to do i'm going to do background
check to find if they have any felonies
all this other stuff no problem my
suggestion if the state you live in and
the country you live in allows do also
credit check why would i do credit check
credit check is fantastic because you'll
learn where their credit score is if
they pay their bills if they don't pay
their bills and it's been consistent for
a long time not paying your bills for
six months could be a challenge you're
facing but not paying your bills for 6
12 24 36 48 months is a habit you're
probably also not going to pay your
bills to your department which means
coming through on whatever assignment's
going to be given to you so rather than
just doing a background check start also
doing a credit check it'll tell you a
lot about the person you're about to
hire so point number three is an obvious
one you know this but it's doing it
which is calling references and when you
call a reference what questions to ask
because here's how reference goes you
have to know that
people are only going to give you
numbers of people they worked for
that
ended well i don't know if that makes
sense like they're not going to put a
number of somebody that didn't end well
so how do you do it here's how you do it
during the interview process you ask
them so
tell me the best experiences you had
with your two favorite bosses you worked
with such and such great what was unique
about it it was great working with this
guy
awesome great you write the names down
first name of the bosses then you say
tell me the boss you work with that you
least
liked working with him or her oh my god
that was bobby oh really okay perfect
tell me why not well here's bobby's
challenge
got it fantastic great
now when it comes down to high ring
they're gonna give you the three
references and the three references are
gonna be there and you're gonna ask
listen do you remember how you told me
about bobby would you mind if i called
bobby
and
something happens to the body language
that body language is going to tell you
if they're like
i would much rather have you not call
bobby
it's a 50 50 risk you're taking you know
what i'm saying in that moment you have
to say well no problem it's totally fine
or you have to say well this is a
concern for me i can't call bobby then
i'm not doing anything here so you
yourself have to make a decision there
but i want to talk to references of
people that are going to tell me the
good the bad and the ugly if i call the
reference and the reference says oh
we love this guy we love her it's
amazing it's awesome you ask him hey
johnny i know you love this person this
is great if this person applied today to
work for your company would you hire
them back
well you know i don't that's a question
you gotta ask so remember good questions
reveal great information
don't get too it's kind of like coming
home and you're dating a guy or a girl
and you're trying to convince your
parents why this is the one and you know
you're avoiding those two questions to
ask about him or her those are the two
questions you gotta ask because marriage
is a long time hiring somebody to get
things done is a long time and hiring
the wrong person can completely set you
back three six twelve months in your
company or that department look this
point number four is an obvious one you
gotta do nowadays some do it some don't
do it you gotta look at their social
media it's that simple you gotta go look
at the social media i wanna see how many
beer bong pictures i'm gonna see i wanna
see what kind of habits you got i want
to see what pictures you take i want to
see what things you're into i want to
see what you like you know the culture
how you i just want to see you have to
do that nowadays because when you hire
somebody that image of that person that
works for you is also the image that
they're living now if you're a very
creative place you're like awesome this
person is outgoing it's great they got a
personality they got things they do
they're fun so they're going to be great
for biz dev but it's a different kind of
a job you may say well this is a little
too risk we don't want to take so don't
be naive and don't go don't go take a
look at their social media take the time
to go look at their social media it's
only going to take you five minutes to
learn enough about them and if you don't
learn anything from them on social media
it's actually probably a good thing
so prior to them coming to the interview
say you put a job posting out there
right and you're not using a recruiting
form we'll get to recruiting from here
in a minute but say you're not using a
recruiting firm and they send an email
i'm interested i'm interested i'm
interested i'm interested have a
10-minute video that talks about your
company
send the link of the video back to 55
people that applied for your company and
say hi john thank you for your interest
in this position i want you to watch
this video and send me an email back on
what you took away from the video and if
our company is actually a culture that
you would fit in and that we would fit
with you as well looking forward to
hearing back from you that email goes
out out of the 55 people that responded
to your email again everything with this
is filtering i'm just giving you ideas
on how to filter the wrong person to
hire that doesn't fit your company right
out of the 55 emails you send back with
the video
half of them are not even going to look
at the email they're like i'm not going
to watch this video the other half are
going to watch the video but they're
going to say this is definitely not the
culture for me
10 of the people that are going to watch
the video are going to say this could
actually be the culture for me they'll
send the email out of the 10 that send
the email to you five of them you're
going to say i want to talk to this guy
so do you create a zoom so you went from
55 to 5 because you also don't want to
waste your time interviewing people that
are not a good interview if you do a
hundred interviews for you for the year
that we're not good interviews times 30
minutes how many hours is that that's a
lot of minutes if you waste a hundred
times 30 that's 3000 minutes you can do
other things and have your focus be
elsewhere so give that email back 10
minutes create a nice video explaining
who the company is preferably by the ceo
some of the employees some of the
customers what the vision is what we've
done
how we work and let the employee that
apply for the job give you an idea if
this is going to be a fit for them as
well another way to filter out employees
that don't fit into your culture
okay so next if i hire somebody
depending on levels they're going to be
interviewed by multiple people everybody
100 is going to go through the filtering
process the references the book the
assignment it doesn't matter whether i'm
hiring a ceo or a c-suite or a director
or manager or just a basic employee but
if i'm hiring a fifteen dollar an hour
person twenty dollar an hour person they
get interviewed by minimum two people
one is the hiring manager one is going
to be that department manager and maybe
i'm gonna get somebody i'll say what do
you think about this person ask
questions maybe i don't think about xyz
great
if it's a director or mid-level
management they're going to be
interviewed around four people and then
if it's a c-suite all the c-suites are
going to interview this person so we
just recently hired a cto
the other six c-suites they all
interviewed the cto and every one of the
c-suites that interviewed the cto send
me an email or a message to tell me what
they liked about them what they saw as a
big opportunity on what they thought
that may be a concern which there wasn't
any with this one that we had right so
it depends on what levels you hire don't
just go with one person hiring them have
somebody else look at them as well to
see if it's going to be fit or not you
will learn more from multiple eyeballs
by people
who understand the company's culture who
are able to reason who have a long-term
vision with the company you gotta also
ask the right person to interview them
outside of yourself so sometimes before
you give somebody a job offer w-2 salary
bonus everything sometimes it makes
sense to hire them as a consultant 1099
and give them a project to see how they
do it for 90 days before you make that
actual offer for them to be full-time so
you'll say listen johnny i like you i
want to bring you on board i don't know
if i want to make a w-2 offer would you
be open to a three-month contract
consultant as a 10.99 to see if you can
get these two different projects done
then based on i will make a full-time
offer to you person is going to say yes
or no great if they say yes you don't
have any risk your only risk is three
times seven thousand dollars is twenty
one thousand dollars and you can't leave
any time soon and the upside is what you
learn three months later if this person
get higher you hire mwt you make an
offer and if it's not you wish them the
best and you move on but at least you
don't put that risk of hr on the w2 side
by simply offering them a 1099 position
for 90 days so before you go out and
hire somebody you want to make sure this
position is filtered out by many of your
different leaders in the following way
one
do we really need to hire a full-time
employee could this be a consultant
could this be 1099 could this be
outsourced do we have to get them
full-time could this be a part-time
position you have to ask all of the what
job do we want them to do can they work
from xyz do they have to be i mean all
of these things that you get before you
say yep this is somebody we need full
time and this is a job that we're going
to need for at least 18 to 24 months
then you go make that offer because if
you just go in and no one's questioning
that this may be just an employee need
for six months or 12 months or 24 months
you may be wasting your time as well as
your resources so asking the question of
exactly who are we hiring why are we
hiring him how much is this task going
to be needed is this a permanent
position is this a temp position and is
w to the best way to take a go about
hiring this individual so so number nine
is more on you not on the employee and
here's what it is sometimes you as the
entrepreneur you have to go and take
inventory of your benefits package you
have as an organization your 401k your
health benefits are the health benefits
set up that only benefits a single young
person what if somebody that's married
with kids and they're thinking about
having a baby does it benefit a family a
wife a husband and kids does your
benefit in 401k in the way you match is
it competitive in the marketplace how do
you work in regards to vacation days per
year bonuses bonus structure moving up
in the company advancement in the
company does a company have a big vision
there's a company have a clear vision of
how me as somebody that's coming up you
could climb up and win in the company
all of those things you got to take
inventory of yourself and the way you do
this is bring somebody in from the
outside consultant to break down your
benefits package and say you know what
you're not as good as these guys are
you're not good in this area you're
strong in this area you may want to
completely improve your benefits package
before you go out there trying to look
for the best employees because generally
the best employees are going to want to
have good packages because they have a
lot of different opportunities out there
now this next one is the outline it's
gonna break every rule i just talked to
but then it's okay because sometimes you
have to know you're taking a risk with
this person here's what it is you just
don't want to do this too often you may
have somebody that comes in
and let's say they do the book
the resume
nothing seems crazy but you have a hunch
you feel good about this guy or this
girl
the risk is not a big risk you have a
little bit of a risk but you just
believe this person can do a lot with
the company long term
if you're willing to take this risk and
you know it you know you're taking a
risk sometimes it makes sense to take a
risk because
years ago somebody had to take a risk on
me and there was no reason for you to
say this guy's gonna go out there and do
something big i don't have a four-year
degree not a two-year degree 1.8 gpa in
high school i just got out of the
military i was a bodybuilder but dave
kirby took a shot with me and said hey
i know you don't have a degree but i'm
willing to hire you at morgan stanley
dean without age of 21 without a degree
in the girl i was going up against for a
job girl named seoul uc berkeley 15 16
or sats she ran a club in berkeley while
she was going to school and got a four
year program in two and a half years and
we were competing for a job dave was
supposed to only give a job to one of us
gave it to both of us 20 some years
later i'm still in the financial
industry if it wasn't for dave kirby i
probably would be back in the military
today so sometimes
you got to take that risk but it has to
be a risk based on soft skills great
attitude attractive attitude charming
charismatic positive take the risk on
the right areas not the hard but the
attitude sucks but the soft skills you
know take the risk and soft skills not
on hard skills
long term it's going to help you out so
that's ten points for you got two more
points that i have bonus content in a
video that you can only find on
valuetainment.com and if you click here
i'm going to give you the pdf as well
but if you want to stay on youtube
there's another video you can watch it's
called how to hire your first employee
as an entrepreneur if you've never
watched it click here and if this video
brought you value give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel take care
everybody
[Music]